hello everyone and welcome to a game
that ended very abruptly from round
eight of the FED Grand Swiss currently
being played it's Sandra Maro of
Argentina Grand Master versus Jeffrey
Shong and um uh well it happens to all
of us and obviously it can happen to a
very strong grandm the game lasted only
14 moves and uh creating the interface
for this game took longer than actually
making the video for this game uh so
let's check it out and hopefully it
doesn't happen to you so Sandro opens
with D4 we have Pawn to D5 C4 and D
captures on C4 okay the Queen's Gambit
accepted is on the board Knight F3 and
now Pawn to A6 Knight to F6 is the main
move to counter at A6 is the second most
popular we have E3 and now Knight to F6
uh guarding with B5 will run into the
usual A4 B5 the challenging of the pawn
chain so after E3 Knight F6 uh we have
Bishop captures on C4 and now Pawn to E6
all right all very standard Stu we have
Castle C5 and now Pawn to B3 this is
like the sixth most popular continuation
capturing on C5 is the main move so B3
and Knight B to D7 we have Bishop to B2
and now Bishop to E7 uh Bishop goes back
to E2 and now we have castles Knight B
to D2 and now Pawn to B6 preparing to F
get to the light Square Bishop Knight to
E5 and Bishop to B7 and this is where
the magic happens Bishop to F3 of course
countering the strong light Square
Bishop and queen to C7 nicely defending
it and it is now as of move 12 already
that we have a completely new game so uh
move 12 completely new game move 14 game
over uh here Rook to C1 was played uh
nicely aligning The Rook with the black
queen and here black played Knight
captures on E5 and you have only one
good response to Knight captures on E5
and that is to capture the Knight on E5
with the pawn D captures on E5 is the
move you should play and after the
Knight moves then you continue with
something like A3 you stop Knight to B4
then Rook comes to d8 maybe aligns
itself with the queen queen to E2 and so
on the game continues uh but after
Knight captures on E5 Bishop captures on
B7 was played and here Sandro uh
obviously mixed up his lines or or maybe
it was just an oversight but it is uh
here that you have a completely winning
position if you find what went wrong so
feel free to pause the video and solve
the position for black or if you've seen
the thumbnail you can also use that for
your your you know uh storage in your
mind uh so yeah uh for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
winning the bishop and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight E to G4 that's the move of course
you get the Knight out of harms away and
there's no defense you're either
checkmating black on H2 white on H2 or
you are winning the free Bishop on B7
there's no way to stop check you play G3
or F4 uh it doesn't really matter you
just Queen captures bishop and now White
is up a full piece white has a bishop
and the Knight black has bishop and two
knights and some of you who are maybe
new to chess um might be thinking well
why did he resign he's only down one
piece maybe he wins it back I mean if he
if he lost it maybe he wins it back and
while that is a fair question uh usually
in in uh top grandm games you don't just
uh blunder a piece and then win it back
although I will remind everyone of the
game Magnus Carlson versus GNE Jones
from the aisle of Men Tournament I
believe it was 2017
uh where Magnus actually blundered a
piece in a classical game continued
playing and won the game but that is
that is Magnus Carlson we're talking
about uh and not not everyone is willing
to commit like four hours of their time
playing a classical game being a piece
down but if you haven't seen that game
uh will be the first link in the
description below so do check it out I
mean it's quite it's quite nice uh so
yeah it can happen to everyone even a
2600 grandm so next time it happens to
you don't be too hard on yourself but um
it's very good for Jeffrey Shan because
this is his first victory of the
tournament he started out very strongly
with five draws against five very strong
Grand Masters then he lost a game then
he drew another one and this is now his
first win so maybe as there are three
more rounds um to be played in the
tournament
maybe he he gets some more wins would be
would be very nice for him uh so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it tough
luck for for Sandro Maro but hopefully
we will all learn from this and not make
the same mistake as he did uh so once
again really hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Steven mccan chess beats
League Roman manini Sim's giant tortois
farm and Marvin Sparrow for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
everything that's happening in the Chess
World H but also covering this
tournament until it ends uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and do check out
magnus's game in the link in the
description below uh see you soon